ce second épisode consacré à louis xiv
mettra en lumière la façon dont son
règne à donner forme à une culture riche
multiples et puissante
il ne lésinaient jamais sur l'effort de
faste de luxe parce que c'est une en
faisait un instrument majeur de sa
politique
[Musique]
nous visiterons en détail le château de
versailles avec lequel louis xiv ébloui
toute l'europe et provoqué l'admiration
du monde entier
louis xiv s'inscrit dans la tradition
des grands rois guerriers la france vue
impliqués dans des conflits armés
une année sur deux durant son règne
lorsque ce dernier approchait de son
terme
la gloire du monarque était déclinante
sa famille en proie à une succession de
tragédies et la france son pays dans un
triste état de vulnérabilité
il en avait pourtant renforcé l'image
dans de nombreux domaines mais ces
grandes expéditions et ses guerres
incessantes et puisèrent le royaume
louis xiv se bercer d'illusions il
prétendait être proche de ses sujets
alors qu'il exerçait une tyrannie ses
succès urt un coût élevé et préparer le
terrain à la révolution de 1789
colbert en bon serviteur du roi devra
améliorer paris à nettoyer les rues et à
les éclairer par des lanternes la
capitale faisait partie du grand projet
destiné à assurer la gloire du roi
l'observatoire le louvre les gobelins
les invalides
l'institut la porte saint denis la place
vendôme la porte des victoires le pont
royal
les champs elysées les tuileries et de
nombreuses fontaines verront le jour au
cours de la seconde moitié du xviie
siècle
colbert n'aime pas à versailles il veut
que le roi soit logé au louvre 1 parce
que le louvre ça doit être le palais du
roi selon lui dans la capitale du
royaume et il fait tout pour que le
louvre de vienne le château qui va
immortaliser la gloire de louis xiv il
fait tout c'est à dire qu'il fait venir
le plus grands artistes du xviie siècle
celui qu'on considère comme le plus
grand c'est à dire le berne à berlin
c'est l'architecte et le sculpteur des
pâtes est assez dur de le faire venir un
an que c'est un exploit
il vient quelques mois en france en 765
elle vient pour donner les plans du
louvre le berlin présente à différentes
esquisses mais colbert se méfiait de la
munificence de son style baroque et
décida de passer commande à claude
perron le bernin aura par la suite
l'occasion d'exécuter une merveilleuse
sculpture équestre de louis xiv
colbert pensait que la famille royale
résidera au lourd mais son intention de
faire de paris une capitale exaltant la
gloire du roi ne sera jamais suivi par
louis xiv qui se désintéresse à petit à
petit de ce projet architectural il ne
voulait pas résidé au louvre et lui
préféra versailles
colbert voyant ce désintérêt voulu faire
du louvre une vitrine des productions
nationales destinées au commerce
il ne pouvait imaginer que louis xiv
emmènerait sa cour ainsi que le
gouvernement à la campagne louis xiv on
le pense c'est pas tout à fait tranché
par les historiens mais louis xiv se
méfier de paris depuis la fronde
il était assez traumatisés par la fuite
cours de son enfance il avait de tout
préparer aller à saint germain peu près
aller dans d'autres endroits
peut-être redoute est il de nouvelles
manifestations de ce type et
pensaient-ils que le fait de résider en
dehors de paris lui assurerait la
sécurité ans résidant à paris il aurait
difficilement pu pratiquer ses passe
temps favoris
son penchant pour les femmes peut
également avoir joué un rôle dans ce
choix
ils se rendaient certainement compte
qu'il lui serait difficile de continuer
à s'amuser sans créer le scandale
puisque en tant que roi il vivait sous
le regard permanent du public
de plus louis tombe amoureux en même
temps de versailles et de louise de la
vallière
celle ci était une cavalière accomplie
ce qui faisait d'elle une compagnie des
halles versailles
à l'origine était un pavillon de chasse
de louis xiii le souvenir des moments
qu'ils y avaient passé ensemble lui
donner à ses yeux une valeur
sentimentale
il interdit lorsqu on rebâtit versailles
que l'on détruit ce pavillon mais louise
qui lui avait inspiré l'idée de
s'établir à cet endroit ni jamais de
chambre dans le château et ne vit jamais
terminé la passion de louis pour les
femmes le fit passer de l'une à l'autre
tandis que son amour pour versailles
demeura inaltérable en 16 168 pour
célébrer la paix qui mettait fin à la
guerre de dévolution et honorer sa
nouvelle maîtresse madame de montespan
louis donne à une grande fête au château
de versailles c'est après cette trêve
que le grand projet de moderniser le
louvre fut abandonnée au profit d'une
entreprise de plus grande envergure
encore resterez versailles la famille du
roi s'agrandissait et louis voulait que
les siens l'accompagnent tout ça
versailles
pendant la construction la famille
royale s'installa à saint germain la
décision de déménager à versailles fut
annoncée en 16 177 ait eu lieu
effectivement en 16 182 aucun architecte
français n'avait l'expérience les
connaissances et l'envergure nécessaire
pour présenter un projet concluant de
restructuration pour le versailles du
roi soleil
c'est ce qui permit à louis xiv
d'imposer ses idées visionnaires comme
ils avaient une expérience limitée des
grands travaux la construction fut en
perpétuelle évolution
car elle été reconsidéré en permanence
par louis pour qui c'était une de ses
occupations favorites
le premier objectif du roi soleil était
de conserver l'ancien château au centre
il ne s'agissait pas de concevoir un
projet dans sa totalité
les architectes devait incorporer les
structures existantes dans leurs plans
versailles
allez refléter parfaitement la
personnalité de louis xiv il se consacra
davantage aux jardins cana demeure
suivant en cela les traces de louis xiii
qui il y avait déjà créé des formes
géométriques
mais il élargit le tout et y ajouta des
pièces d'eau sa conception de versailles
étaient inspirés par les mythes
classique des métamorphoses d ovide
leroy désiré égaler la gloire des
anciens dieux et héros
chaque élément avait pour base une
allégorie le moindre détail témoignez
d'une remarquable maîtrise de
l'ornementation il était clair que cette
et louis mû par sa passion et une vision
bien arrêté qui était à la tête du
projet mais il y avait aussi quatre
hommes sont la collaboration desquels il
n'aurait jamais pu faire aboutir son
rêve
colbert le nôtre le veau et le brun
ils étaient plus âgés que lui mais aussi
remarquable qu'ils fussent ils les
dominer était le moteur de cette
entreprise exceptionnelle
colbert détestait ce projet en raison
des sommes qui l'obligeait à prélever
sur les finances du pays mais il réussit
toutefois à trouver les sommes
considérables que nécessitèrent au cours
des années les différentes phases de
construction andré le nôtre qui avait
étudié les jardins italien fut le
jardinier de louis xiv
pendant presque tout son règne il créa
les jardins de versailles marly saint
cloud et chantilly
[Musique]
louis qui étaient souvent plus à l'aise
avec ses serviteurs qu'avec les
aristocrates qui l'entouraient
l'apprécié beaucoup
la conception des jardins surpasser en
importance celle du château
la plus grande partie des fonds dédiés à
la première tranche de construction à
versailles fut dépensés à cet effet
il fallut en particulier faire de gros
travaux de terrassement et assécher les
terrains marécageux des centaines
d'orange et furent apportées sur des
charrettes les fleurs exotiques
représenté à l'égal de l'or la
prospérité louis adoré les fleurs quand
ils n'étaient pas en guerre avec la
hollande il en importait 4 millions de
bulles de parents il aimait aussi les
fleurs d'oranger les tubéreuse les
giroflées les narcisses et le jasmin du
14 va se passionner pour le château de
de son père il va avoir aussi plaisir à
venir chasser la chasse est vraiment le
divertissement rechercher dans les
environs il va demander à louis le vau à
d'agrandir le château car il veut le
préserver et donc lui le veau va faire
une enveloppe de pierres autour du petit
château en iso trois couleurs c'est à
dire bleus de l'ardoisé rouge de la
brique et blanc de la pierre il fit
construire ce qu'on appelle l' enveloppe
de leveaux qui entoure le château déjà
existants et construisit devant celle ci
les nouveaux bâtiments
le roi décida qu'il préférait avoir une
aile plus importante pour les serviteurs
qu'un plus grand palais
c'est ce qui fut réalisé au milieu des
années 16 180 le grand canal fut creusée
et l'on commença à construire
l'extension vers l'ouest celle-ci
imposante était en pierre et non plus en
brique et orné de colonnes classique
à l'intérieur l'espace au sol et est
quadruplé par la construction de trois
ailes qui enfermaient la cour de marbre
tout en laissant intact le château
paternel et la façade est
[Musique]
le vous commencez à la construction de
l'appartement du roi au nord de l'est
l'ouest en 16 170 les appartements de la
reine était presque aussi vaste que ceux
du roi ceux de madame de montespan était
situé au sommet du grand escalier et
disposaient d'un accès aux appartements
du roi
leveaux consulte également la cour de
marbre de versailles entre est destiné
aux dignitaires arrivant de paris on en
admire aujourd'hui encore le décor
sculpté
leveaux mourut brusquement en 16 170
jules hardouin mansart le remplaça
auprès du roi en 16 179 et devint le
plus célèbre architecte de son temps en
16 160 de charles le brun fut anobli et
devint premier peintre du roi mais
c'était un décorateur d'intérieur hors
pair il s'entendait bien avec leveaux
qui le chargea de la décoration
intérieure de versailles il dirigera
également les gobelins le grand atelier
qu'une fabrique est pas uniquement des
tapisseries mais presque tous les tissus
dont le château avait besoin
cette tapisserie de lebrun montre le roi
en visite aux gobelins pour la seconde
tranche de travaux
le premier objectif fut de placer des
sculptures dans les jardins lebrun créé
à des groupes de statue allégorique pour
orner les fontaines et les parterres
d'où l'air le soir le midi et le point
du jour le printemps lots décor le
bassin de latone achevée en 16 168 le
bassin d'apollon vit le jour en 16 171
et les bassins d saison en seize 172
le prestige de louis xiv et la renommée
de versailles sa croûte d'année en année
d'autres princes européens désiraient
avoir leur versailles et le coup pierre
jusqu'au moindre détail d'ameublement
colbert profita de cette mode pour
encourager l'exportation ont créé à des
fabriques pour produire les tissus les
rubans la soie la verrerie les tapis la
joaillerie la marqueterie et les autres
articles de luxe qui venait d'habitude
de l'étranger en particulier d'italie
tous ces articles furent bientôt produit
en france
il était d'une qualité bien supérieure à
tout ce qu'on avait vu auparavant
car les artisans français comme
aujourd'hui étaient les meilleurs du
monde
[Musique]
colbert réduisit les dépenses pendant la
guerre de hollande de 16 172 contre les
provinces unifiée l'unrwa a voulue à
toute force terminer les travaux de
versailles et ne se soucient guère des
conséquences financières
quand la guerre a pris fin six ans plus
tard la troisième tranche de
construction pu enfin reprendre
sérieusement à versailles
l'austérité du trianon de marbre de mon
s'arrêtait en avant sur l' architecture
de son temps le palais de louis xiv
devait être le signe extérieur de la
supériorité de la france sur les pays
qui l'entourent est le grand nom qui est
resté attaché au château de versailles
c'est bien évidemment jules hardouin
mansart donc qui va établir une relation
très étroite avec le roi presque
d'amitié il deviendra d'ailleurs
surintendant des bâtiments donc ministre
en 799 et l'essentiel je dirais de
versailles tel qu'on le voit aujourd'hui
c'est l'oeuvre de jules hardouin mansart
mansart réalise à la galerie des glaces
une des merveilles du monde occidental
reliant les appartements du roi et de la
reine encadrés par le salon de la paix
et de la guerre
la galerie des glaces est orné en son
plafond de magnifiques peintures
représentant les grands événements
politiques et guerriers du règne de
louis xiv sous la forme d'allégorie les
deux grandes ailes qui flanquent
l'enveloppent de leveau furent terminés
l'ale sud étaient destinés au prince de
son aux enfants illégitimes et à leur
domesticité entre celle ci et la ville
se trouvaient des logis qui pouvait
accueillir 1500 serviteur des centaines
de courtisans étaient entassés dans la
halle nord destinée à la noblesse
c'était un labyrinthe de couloirs où les
étrangers se perdaient à tout coup au
fur et à mesure de l'avancement du
chantier des jardins de plus en plus de
bassins et fontaines apparaissait et
avec elles des besoins en eau
grandissant bientôt les sources et étant
avoisinants ne suffirent plus il fallut
alors avoir recours à l'eau de la seine
mais l'éloignement du cours d'eau et le
dénivelé entre versailles et ce dernier
était trop important pour avoir recours
aux procédés traditionnels louis xiv fit
alors appel à deux ingénieurs liégeois
suallem et deux villes il lui proposait
un projet révolutionnaire pour l'époque
la machine de marly une pompe aux
dimensions titanesques composé de 14
heures ou à aubes de 12 m de diamètre
grâce à cette installation les eaux du
fleuve pouvait être pompée et acheminé
154 mètres plus haut jusqu'à l'aqueduc
de louveciennes également construit à
cette occasion qui permettait à l'eau
d'atteindre marly puis versailles par
simple gravité
on construisit des étables et des
chenils en 1701
on comptait 6 me à versailles la famille
royale en possédait 400 couples l'unique
événement de la quatrième et dernière
tranche fut la construction de la
chapelle
elle fut interrompue en 16 189 avec
l'éclatement de la guerre et ne put
reprendre que dix ans plus tard en 16
199 après le traité de ryswick la
chapelle fut consacrée en 1710
la création de versailles était un acte
audacieux que ne peut égaler que la
construction de saint pétersbourg par
pierre le grand
l'éducation du jeune roi avait eu pour
but de lui inculquer les valeurs dont
ils auraient besoin pour mettre en
oeuvre la vision de richelieu pour la
france la gloire pour le roi c'est le
moyen de imposé son nom et son règne
pour la postérité il est fasciné par les
figures du passé
alexandre legrand dont le nom retenti
partout plusieurs siècles après leur
mort et il veut la même chose pour
lui-même et pour son royaume et pour
accueillir cette gloire il ya deux
moyens il ya les a et il ya la guerre
louis assuming ce projet et le porta à
l'extrême son se soucier de ce que cela
coûterait en souffrance et en morts il
s'agissait véritablement de construire
la perception que le peuple devait avoir
de la royauté l'image mythologique du
roi soleil fut élaboré avec tant de
maîtrise que le roi lui même ne pouvait
plus en distinguer le caractère
illusoire
les dépenses illimitées de louis xiv
pour la construction et l'aménagement de
versailles semble révéler un amour fou
pour sa propre image
colbert essaya de ramener le roi à la
réalité il averti des conséquences de
ces folles extravagance versaillaise le
pays frôlait la faillite
colbert c'était l'homme qui tenait les
cordons de la bourse
même si ses cordes ont été en permanence
teysseyré par l'appétit royal de
grandeur colbert averti le roi que s'il
n'écoute pas ses conseils il court au
désastre
[Musique]
dans ce qui est amusant c'est qu'on a
plusieurs lettres de colbert où le
ministre fait des réprimandes au roi on
peut appeler ça comme ça c'est à dire il
lui dit votre majesté c'est qu'à
versailles
elle est prisonnière de ses
divertissements elle est au milieu de
ses plaisirs
mais louis xiv ne se détourna pas de sa
quête de magnificence d'autres rois de
france s'y sont succédé par la suite
mais versailles reste encore aujourd'hui
le château de louis xiv
[Musique]
ces grands conquérants ressemble à ces
fleuves débordée qui ravagent tout les
fertiles campagne qu'il devrait
seulement arrosée fernand louis xiv fut
l'un des monarques européens les plus
efficaces sur le plan politique toute
son éducation était pensée pour lui
faire comprendre que la conquête
militaire était un objectif primordial
pourtant certains pensent qu'il aurait
pu aussi bien obtenir par des traités ce
qu'il a obtenu par les armes
à la fin de son règne son manque de
modération se révéla désastreux a alors
que n'at-on pas dit sur l'appétit
guerrier louis xiv est bien là aussi
jugement très sévère de l'histoire et
puis aggravée par les dernières paroles
de louis xiv
lorsqu'il ville et à son arrière petit
fils chez trophée mais les bâtiments
fait trop aimé la guerre ne limitait pas
on ne peut pas dire que louis xiv est
trop aimé la guerre en revanche il a été
dans une situation parce que c'était le
contexte de l'époque il était dans une
situation où il fallait constamment
faire la guerre parce qu'il y avait des
menaces au cours des années il lui des
variations de population mais on estime
que la france comptait alors 20 millions
d'habitants
cette importante population permettait
de lever une armée de 15000 hommes à la
consternation du reste de l'europe
louis xiv pensait être un grand général
en chef
il savourait les flatteries de ses
courtisans qui le maintenaient dans
cette illusion louis xiv a été formée
militairement par turenne
mais dire que c'est un grand général en
chef certainement pas il est allé au
début pour la campagne de flandre
observer les combats mais jamais dans la
mêlée vous savez loin d'henri iv qui lui
monte à cheval et savez être au coeur de
la bataille
louis xiv regarder ça très loin bon
c'était probablement un bon tacticien
mais il savait également s'entourer de
très bon officier
quand louis pris les rênes du
gouvernement en 16e 161 il n'existait
pas de roi des armes l'armée française
était une bande désorganisée qui n'avait
jamais été prise en main depuis l'époque
féodale
elle fut transformée en une formidable
machine de guerre que le roi mis au
service de sa politique étrangère
on n'était pas colonel parce qu'on avait
on avait
de grande qualité militaire on était
colonel parce qu'on achetait un régiment
donc il y avait des systèmes de double
commandement
en réalité il y avait de véritables
hommes de guerre qui faisait le métier
des armes
et puis toutes sortes d'états majors qui
pratiquait la guerre en dentelles
françois letellier marquis de louvois
exercé à la charge de secrétaire d'état
de la guerre que lui transmis son père
michel letellier avec l'accord du roi
louvois avait la réputation d'être
grossier arrogant brusque et tête brûlée
louis xiv la réorganiser l'armée
française parce qu'elle était un peu
fatigué après le règne de louis xiii
grâce notamment à colbert parce que
c'est même colbert il a remis sur pied
et quand colbert sera ton bras un petit
peu en disgrâce est bien celle où voix
qui lui sera véritablement le
restructurateur de la grande armée du
roi soleil
en 16 165 louvois commença en tant que
secrétaire d'état de la guerre a oeuvré
sous les ordres du roi il mis l'accent
sur l'amélioration du recrutement en
instaurant un système de critères minima
pour l'enrôlement le paiement de
l'uniforme de la nourriture du logement
et les soins aux blessés
louis xiv est représentée ici lors de la
fondation en 16 174 de l'hôtel royal des
invalides
un établissement où les soldats
invalides pouvaient recevoir aide et
assistance la mort en 16 167 de philippe
iv d'espagne père de marie thérèse
épouse de louis xiv pousse à ce dernier
a formé des prétentions au nom de sa
femme sur plusieurs provinces espagnoles
c'est ainsi que la france déclenché à la
guerre de dévolution contre les pays-bas
espagnols voici louis xiv et marie
thérèse à arras en 16 167 au cours de la
guerre droit de france à travers une
série de capitulation et le traité d'aix
la chapelle gagne à beaucoup de villes
importantes dans les flandres
après des années de victoires aisées dû
au talent de ses lieutenants
louis xiv convaincu qu'il contrôle et où
s'attribua le crédit des nombreux succès
de ses armées et il pense à bientôt
pouvoir remporter six victoires en
dirigeant les opérations depuis
versailles
mais le contingent finit par s'épuiser
et il fallait toujours demander au roi
ces instructions avant de procéder à une
quelconque manoeuvre
les délais liés à son éloignement weyer
lui coûter sa couronne
le génie de louvois et la crainte de
louis devant un pouvoir décentralisé
eurent pour conséquence la
centralisation et l'éloignement du
pouvoir s'étaient risqués mais la
création d'une nouvelle armée française
est une des réussites les plus
remarquables du xviie siècle la guerre
de hollande pris fin avec une série de
traités c'est ce qu'on appelle la paix
de nimègue qui donne à la france la
franche comté et la majeure partie des
pays bas elle marque l'apogée de sa
gloire militaire ses plans de conquête
ne se limitait pas au continent européen
en seize 181,2 l'explorateur français
lesueur de la salle revendiqua pour la
france toutes les terres le long du
fleuve mississippi et leur donna le nom
de louisiane en l'honneur de son voix
[Musique]
seize 183 est une année de transition la
reine meure et louis épouse madame de
maintenon
c'est aussi l'année de la mort de
colbert les guerres qui avait fait rage
pendant presque toute sa carrière avait
été un obstacle majeur qu'il avait dû
affronter
il lui avait fallu augmenter les impôts
pour soutenir les efforts de guerre et
régler les énormes dépenses liées à la
construction de versailles après sa mort
les difficultés s'accumulent ère pour le
roi
le secrétaire de la guerre louvois
n'avait plus de rival et louis xiv
n'était plus freiné par les sages
conseils de colbert la france se lança
dans plusieurs conflits en 16 184
l'empereur leopold deux premiers du
saint empire germanique et charles deux
salles hier aux pays bas et la suède
dans une coalition anti française vienne
fut assiégée par les turcs
la menace ottomane pousse à l'empereur a
signé le traité de ratisbonne qui
permettait à la france de garder entre
autres le luxembourg et strasbourg
ce tableau allégorique représente le
traité de ratisbonne le roi est
couronnée par la victoire
flanqué de la guerre et de la paix les
deux lions symbolise la hollande et la
suède
l'aigle est l'emblème du saint-empire
romain germanique
le drame des protestants français
les huguenots reste une tache indélébile
sur l'image du roi soleil prisonniers de
l'opinion publique et des pressions du
clergé il se trouve a forcé de lancer
une opération contre eux à la suite des
guerres religieuses qui avait fait rage
entre 15 162 et 15 198 le roi henri iv
grand père de louis xiv avait signé
l'édit de nantes
la france se différencier ainsi des
autres pays européens où seule la
religion d'état a été reconnu henri iv
qui étaient protestants se converti à la
religion catholique mais il se bâtit
pour que les huguenots avec qui il avait
lutté obtiennent certains droits en
particulier celui de tenir un culte en
public et d'éduquer leurs enfants dans
leur religion
l'hostilité à l'égard des protestants
semblait surtout une réponse à leur
réussite commerciale
ils constituaient des communautés très
puissante et était à la tête des pays
les mieux éduquées les plus habiles le
clergé exigea le lancement d'une
campagne de conversion au catholicisme
et louis xiv quelques années plus tard
peut-être également incité par une femme
qui est madame de maintenon qui n'avait
pas tellement les protestants les
parpaillon comme elle les appelait var
évoqué sept et dix mille îles leur
évoque surtout parce que les protestants
sont les alliés de l'angleterre et il
m'a carrément rolls et on est
constamment en guerre avec l'angleterre
donc la cause est entendue il décide
cette révocation
hélas en 16 169 un grand nombre de nos
s'étaient installés sans bruit en
angleterre et en hollande
en seize 180 les persécutions s'accentue
r on utilisait la corruption et la
brutalité pour convertir les protestants
au catholicisme
louis xiv révoqua l'édit de nantes en 16
ils dénient aux protestants les droits
civils et religieux garantie par henri
iv un élan ça contre les dragonnades
pour les forcer à se convertir ce qu'on
appelle les dragonnades c'est le
logement des gens de guerre et vous
imaginez que loger des gens de guerre
c'est mettre à mal les familles leurs
biens ça va provoquer des conversions
quand même en nombre qui vont faire
croire aux rois et qu' il n'y a plus
désormais qu'à abolir s'était dit
puisque il n'y aurait plus ou quasi plus
de protestants dans le royaume
c'est une décision clairement
malheureuse le roi se rendit compte que
cette campagne de conversion était un
échec complet
alors évidemment cette révocation de
10,90 est complètement catastrophique
néfaste parce que les protestants sont
des gens brillants intelligents des
entrepreneurs surtout des entrepreneurs
richissime pour la plupart et qui vont
quitter le pays pour aller travailler
ailleurs
donc que la france va se retrouver
quasiment mise en faillite à cause de
cette révocation
près de cinquante mille louis d'or avait
quitté le royaume en catimini il avait
perdu 9 milles de ses meilleurs marins
600 de ses officiers 12000 soldat de
première classe
c'était une catastrophe irréparable pour
la société française
de plus ce conflit intérieur tragique eu
pour conséquence la perte de confiance
envers la couronne la misère la peur la
haine la corruption la sauvagerie
l'inimitié de toute l'europe et la
désapprobation du pape mais le roi avait
des préoccupations plus urgentes en 16
186 l'empereur leopold et les dirigeants
d'espagne de suède de saxe du palatinat
et de brandebourg formèrent la ligne
d'augsbourg pour mettre un frein à
l'expansion française française 185 la
mort du frère de la princesse palatine
réveilla les appétits expansionnistes de
la france
louis xiv estimait que sa belle-soeur
liselotte pouvait prétendre à la
succession de son frère en 16 288
prétextant devoir se défendre contre la
ligue d'augsbourg il ordonnait la
destruction de mannheim et dale dahlberg
[Musique]
le duc de saxe rejoignit la ligue et la
guerre fut déclenchée
à la fin de la même année la naissance
de jacques stuart prince de galles
héritiers catholique du trône
d'angleterre oblige à ses parents
jacques ii et son épouse à fuir devant
la conspiration
guillaume d'orange accepta de succéder à
jacques 2 et de sauver le protestantisme
anglais le roi de france n'avait pas
prévu ce mouvement audacieux comme il
était occupé en allemagne guillaume pu
prendre la mer filer vers l'angleterre
arrivée à torby et marcher sur londres
si louis n'avait pas choisi d'attaquer
l'allemagne il aurait été en mesure
d'empêcher la destitution de jacques de
la famille royale anglaise cherchent un
refuge en france
elle fut chaleureusement accueilli par
louis xiv est installé à saint germain
en 789 guillaume d'orange et son épouse
devaient souverain conjoint sous le nom
de guillaume iii et mary ii d'angleterre
et rejoignirent la ligue d'augsbourg
qu'on appela désormais la grande
alliance la france déclarait la guerre à
l'angleterre
jacques de rejoignit l'irlande pour
rallier les catholiques contre les
souverains anglais
les manoeuvres de louis xiv pour
soutenir jacques ii dans sa reconquête
du trône était un peu tardive
guillaume iii remporta la victoire sur
son rival qui retourna à saint germain
en 16 192 la victoire navale anglaise
lors de la bataille de la hougue et face
à toute menace d'invasion française mais
le roi de france continuent à témoigner
sa générosité et sa compassion envers la
famille exilée et les accueilli chez lui
l'opinion européenne se retourna contre
louis et ses campagnes militaires furent
moins glorieux les attaques et les
railleries se multiplièrent contre lui
en seize 196 le duc de savoie abandonna
la grande alliance et la phase de la
guerre changea en 16 197 le traité de
ryswick mis fin à la guerre de la ligue
d'augsbourg louis xiv dû faire de
nombreuses concessions
il fut forcé de reconnaître ans
guillaume iii le roi d'angleterre
d'écossé et d'irlande de restituer la
rive droite du rhin et la lorraine et
une partie des pays-bas néerlandais
espagnol au traité de turin et risvik eh
bien on perd des tas de choses mais on
récupère quand même strasbourg et une
partie de l'alsace est également saint
domingue et saint domingue qui nous est
cédée par les anglais va quand même nous
permettre de devenir le premier pays
producteur de sucre le journal de l'art
elle confirme qu'à cette période
le roi était conscient de la pauvreté
qui se développer dans son royaume et
qu'il désirait vraiment alléger la
charge de ces sujets elle écrit leroy c
les souffrances de son peuple
ils cherchent tous les moyens de la
soulager peut-être le souhaite et il met
les milliers de pauvres réduit à une
misère chronique n'était pas sa priorité
son désir de conquérir l'europe
l'empêché de voir qu'il était le
responsable des souffrances de son
peuple
quand on lui faisait remarquer le poids
que les impôts faisait peser sur ces
sujets il préféré penser que leur
pauvreté étaient liés au mauvais temps
et aux maigres récoltes
toute chose qui ne dépendait pas de lui
17 cents fut une année faste pour la
france charles ii d'espagne meurt il
avait désigné pour héritier philippe
d'anjou petit fils de louis xiv
celui ci accède au trône d'espagne sous
le nom de philippe 5,6 louis xiv avait
pu prévoir l'avenir est ce que cela
signifierait pour son pays
il ne leur est jamais permis il ne
pouvait s'opposer à la possibilité de
créer un royaume à deux têtes entre la
france et l'espagne mais bientôt aller
se déclencher la guerre de succession de
l'espagne pour winston churchill
il s'agissait de la première guerre
mondiale étant donné le nombre de pays
qui étaient mêlés l'angleterre la
hollande et l'autriche salière contre la
france il reconnaissait en l'archiduc
autrichien le roi charles iii d'espagne
en 1703 la savoie et le portugal se
joignirent à la grande alliance 2704 à
10 709 le duc de marlboro et le prince
eugène de savoie remporté ensemble
plusieurs victoires contre les français
ils les chassèrent de blé naïm en
bavière prirent barcelone bruxelles
anvers et l'italie du nord puis furent
vainqueur à oudenaarde et s'emparèrent
de gand et bruges
la guerre fut longue et désastreuse pour
louis xiv à la cour la vie changea
complètement les fonds destinés au
château de versailles devait être
consacrée au conflit
l'atmosphère de restriction créer un
climat de troubles et de tristesse
chacun avait vu un membre de sa famille
mourir au combat ou rentrer chez lui
gravement blessé les français désiraient
ardemment vivre enfin en paix l'année 10
709 vie le pire hiver qu'on ait connu
les récoltes furent désastreuses les
conditions de vie de la paysannerie
française était de plus en plus terrible
louis xiv contraint de faire la paix
trouva les termes qui lui était offert
tellement humiliant qu'il préféra
poursuivre la guerre à la tête d'un pays
affamé
on estime que la famine et le froid
emportèrent huit cent mille personnes
[Musique]
la guerre n'a pris fin qu'en 1713
avec le traité d'utrecht les douze ans
de guerre avait mis la france à genoux
une famille paysanne une banqueroute
financière et une défaite militaire
dès l'été le prix exorbitant de la
politique de louis xiv
désireux de créer la dissension entre
ses voisins au point d' affamer son
peuple
[Musique]
la gloire de louis xiv dans le royaume
et à l'étranger atteignit son apogée
vers 16 280 l'année où se maria le grand
dauphin
en seize 181,2 versailles devint
officiellement la résidence royale la
demeure de la cour et le siège du
gouvernement
et étrangement cette date marque le
déclin de la popularité du roi
[Musique]
dans les dernières décennies de son
règne jusqu'à sa mort en 1715 louis xiv
devint le souverain absolu qu'il
aspirait à être en 785 le roi se rallier
à la vision de madame de maintenon qui
désirait créer une école destinée aux
jeunes filles pauvres de naissance noble
une idée en avance sur son temps elle
était en mesure de suivre sa véritable
vocation
l'éducation des enfants et s'impliquera
fortement dans les activités
quotidiennes de l'école de saint cyr
l'europe prenez plaisir aux productions
musicales et théâtrales que jean racine
y organisait le grand dauphin et son
épouse donnèrent naissance à trois
enfants en bonne santé
l'affection de louis xiv aller au duc du
maine le fils aîné qu'il avait eu avec
madame de montespan ainsi qu'à une
nouvelle venue à la cour marie adélaïde
de savoie elle arriva en 796 alors que
louis avait 59 ans elle va par sa
jeunesse par sa vie c'est cette une
enfance et une enfant extrêmement gay
qui va prendre beaucoup de libertés avec
le roi avec madame de maintenon saint
simon raconte comment elle est toujours
comment elle commet elle embrasse le roi
comment elle elle seule elle s'assoit
sur sur la côte war de son fauteuil
elle va donner un peu de gaieté un peu
de vie à la cour de versailles qui à ce
moment là est un peu morne
[Musique]
en 796 la france toujours en guerre avec
la ligue d'augsbourg saisi une
opportunité de paix le traité de turin
fut négocié et signé
lorsque victor amédée 2 de savoie
changea de camp et abandonna la grande
alliance pour se rallier au roi de
france
le traité devait être scellé par le
mariage du duc de bourgogne petit fils
de louis xiv
âgé de presque 14 ans c'était le fils
aîné de monsieur avec la fille de victor
amédée marie-adélaïde âgé alors de 10
ans et demi on pensait que les
fiançailles des deux enfants mènerait à
la paix l'année suivante en 16 197 le
traité de ryswick mis fin à la guerre de
la ligue d'augsbourg qui avait duré neuf
ans la mère de marie adélaïde et he had
marie d'orléans fille de monsieur et de
sa première épouse henriette anne
d'angleterre
elle avait quitté versailles pour la
cour italienne en se mariant avec victor
amédée
douze ans plus tard sa fille la
charmante et très vive marie-adélaïde de
savoie âgé de 11 ans revenait de turin à
versailles
le roi fut fort contents de découvrir
que sa mère lui avait appris à admirer
la culture française elle avait fort
bien préparer à la vie à la cour de
france dès son arrivée la petite
princesse enchanta tout ce qu'il a
rencontrée et elle devint bientôt la
préférée du roi le duc de bourgogne très
pieux n'aimait pas autant se divertir
que marié adélaïde
en raison de son jeune âge la petite
princesse s'attache à d'abord à madame
de maintenon et au roi les lettres
qu'elle envoie chez elle mentionne le
roi et madame qu'elle appelait tente
bien plus fréquemment que le duc de
bourgogne comme elle était bien jeune et
que son éducation n'était pas achevé
leroy langeois ni de suivre les cours de
l'école de saint cyr deux jours par
semaine du début du siècle jusqu'à la
mort du roi quinze ans plus tard
celui-ci connu plus de deuils que de
plaisir et plus de défaites que de
victoires
ils recherchaient l'esprit malicieux
aimable d'adélaïde pour éclairer séjour
assombri sa présence était une chance
pour madame de maintenon qui n'était
nullement intéressé à divertir la cour
c'est l'image la plus célèbre de louis
xiv dans ces dernières années ce tableau
a été peint par hyacinthe rigaud en 1701
il a représenté un monarque absolu et un
gentilhomme élégante louis xiv à 60 ans
et il est plus malade qu'il n'en a l'air
ici enveloppé dans le manteau du pouvoir
la bouteille de sa jeunesse a disparu ne
lui laissant qu'un air majestueux
teintée de mélancolie
l'unique enfant du roi mourut cette
année là
louis xiv s'adoucit vers la fin de sa
vie il avait rarement le temps de se
divertir
il n'avait plus de conseillers il
travaillait 9 à 10 heures par jour est
passé des heures concentrer sur sa
future stratégie militaire et en second
lieu sur les affaires de l'état à la
cour la jeune génération prenait sa
place
les figures centrales en était philippe
d'orléans fils du frère de louis xiv et
de liselotte princesse palatine et le
jeune armand de bourbon prince de conti
comme louis l'avait prédit
adélaïde continua à porter chance à la
cour son premier bébé en 1704 était un
garçon mais elle le perdre ya un nom
puis à lui encore deux garçons le duc de
bretagne n'est en 1707 et le duc d'anjou
né en 1710 sénescence furent les seules
nouvelles heureuse
au cours de cette guerre interminable
pendant toute cette époque le dauphin
est la dauphine formait un couple
heureux
louis et françoise voyaient en eux un
futur grand couple royal jamais la
succession au trône n'avait été à ce
point assuré
mais en 1711 la france voit la mort des
trois dauphins en moins d'une année sur
la succession de louis xiv il ya des
pages admirables de saint simon il
explique la succession des grands
malheurs c'était c'était terrible le
dauphin le fils du dauphin tout le monde
meurt au tour de louis xiv et donc on ne
sait plus trop qui va hériter le grand
dauphin fils de louis xiv était d'une
forte constitution et avait toujours été
en excellente santé
mais il contracta la variole d'abord il
semble à bien s'en remettre
mais la mode des médecins de saigner
leurs malades provoque à son
affaiblissement
et il mourut d'une crise cardiaque
en 1712 marie-adélaïde de savoie
duchesse de bourgogne apprenait son rôle
de dauphine quand elle succomba à la
rougeole
la princesse palatine voyant les
traitements que lui faisait subir les
médecins tentent à d'intervenir mais
elle en fut empêchée par madame de
maintenon la cour entière fut
bouleversée quand marie adélaïde s'ils
vivaient si populaire mourut à seulement
30 ans quelques jours plus tard le petit
fils est l'arrière petit fils du roi la
suivirent dans la mort pour eux aussi
les médecins ne firent qu'aggraver la
situation
louis en fut si à l'armée que dans un
mouvement de désespoir il rendit les
enfants qui l'avaient tu de madame de
montespan éligibles à la succession au
trône
mais cela ne fut pas nécessaire
l'arrière petit fils de louis xiv le duc
d'anjou dernier né du duc et de la
duchesse avait deux ans il survécu à la
maladie grâce à sa gouvernante la
duchesse de ventadour
elle ne dit pas aux médecins qu'il était
malade et au lieu de cela l'emmena dans
ses propres appartements où elle le
nourrit au sein et le garda bien au
chaud il recouvre à la santé et trois
ans plus tard succède à louis xiv il
devint roi sous le nom de louis 15 la
régence étant assurée par philippe duc
d'orléans
cette succession de disparition at any
louis en plein coeur et il ne songe à
plus à se divertir avec la cour
il ne parvint jamais à oublier les
doubles funérailles du dauphin et de la
dauphine de france saint simon écrivit
un peu plus tard à propos de la mort
d'adélaïde son deuil n'a jamais cessé il
demeure une tristesse secrète un
terrible vide que rien ne peut remplir
versailles comme si son existence
n'avait plus de sens voyelles lentement
partir les courtisans qui reste est
encore
mais la victoire de denain fut une
occasion de se réjouir de nouveau elle
mena au traité d'utrecht en 1713 qui mit
fin à la guerre de succession d'espagne
en 1714 la tragédie frappe a de nouveau
quand le petit fils de louis le bien
aimé duc de berry troisième fils du
dauphin et second dans la succession au
trône après le duc d'anjou mourut des
suites d'un accident de chasse on peut
voir la duchesse de berry dans ses
voiles de veuvage noir et blanc à
fontainebleau maintenant louis xiv
n'avait plus qu'un seul descendant
légitime de la lignée des bourbons si le
petit dauphin mouret le choix de son
successeur se tiendrait entre le neveu
du roi et ses bâtards à moins que ce qui
était le plus probable le petit fils de
louis xiv philippe 5 d'espagne ne
revendiquent le trône de france en
sauvant la vie du futur roi louis 15
madame de ventadour évita certainement
une guerre à la france
le roi ne pouvait que penser que la mort
de ses proches bien aimé de presque
toute sa descendance de sa chair
adélaïde relevait du jugement de dieu un
dieu qui fut clément envers le roi
puisque il vécut encore deux ans à la
fin
louez montrera des signes d'humilité et
se repentit d'avoir tant chercher la
gloire et les plaisirs durant sa vie le
duc d'anjou un joli petit garçon de 5
ans et demi qui ressemblait terriblement
à sa mère avec ses grands yeux et ses
longs cils noirs fut amené pour voir son
arrière-grand-père
on connaît la scène louis xiv sur son
lit de mort qui fait venir le tout petit
bonhomme de cinq ans qu'est le futur roi
bien aimé le futur louis 15 il lui prend
la main et lui dit ne l'imité en rien
surtout pas dans la guerre j'ai trop
aimé la guerre et il sait que la france
est quand même relativement exemple qu'à
ce moment-là fatigué on a combien de
fois n'at-on pas fait fondre les
vaisselles de la cour pour pouvoir payer
les soldats donc le règne n'est pas
en bonne santé à la fin du règne de
louis xiv louer vécu beaucoup plus
longtemps qu'on ne le pensait mais il
mourut quatre jours avant son 77e
anniversaire le 1er septembre 1715 il ne
mesurait cas m 65
mais certains se souvenant de lui
parlait d'un homme d'un mètre 80 l'image
il s'était forgé ainsi que celle de sa
cour sont éternels son désir
d'absolutisme le poussa à diriger le
pays dans tous les domaines
il était à la tête de sa famille des
tribunaux des armées ainsi que des
affaires intérieures et étrangères
ces réalisations sont les suivantes
unité nationale gouvernement centralisé
discipline militaire développement et
exportation de la culture française
ses succès ainsi que la durée de son
règne fonde lui l'archétype du monarque
absolu le règne de louis xiv vite éclore
la culture riche diverse et puissante du
xviie siècle français le roi soleil
ébloui toute l'europe
ça court était envié du monde entier
pourtant s'il développe à son royaume
dans de multiples domaines les guerres
et les grandes expéditions le myrte à
genoux
[Musique]
louis xiv ne parvint jamais à résoudre
le dilemme entre son rôle de puissant
roi soleil destiné à construire et
maintenir la grandeur de la france et sa
culpabilité lorsqu'il voyait les effets
de sa politique sur son peuple il pris
des mesures pour alléger ses souffrances
mais elle n'était que provisoire il ne
fallait en aucun cas qu'elle ne
compromette ses désirs d'expansion
territoriale mais plutôt qu'elles
entretiennent sa glorieuse images pour
réconcilier ces décisions politiques
agressives et leurs effets désastreux
sur son peuple
avec sa confiance il sait leur est au
point de se croire réellement concernés
par la situation de ce dernier alors
même qu il l'écrasé sous le poids de sa
tyrannie
ce n'est qu'à la fin de sa vie sa
famille décimée son royaume
considérablement affaibli que louis xiv
semble à changer de voie pressant le
jeune dauphin de ne pas recourir
systématiquement à la guerre
ces entreprises eurent un coût élevé et
firent le lit de la révolution qui mit
fin à la monarchie mais l'état moderne
lui survécu
[Musique]